North Korea's long-range missile test
may dominate president Trump's talked
with the presidents of Russia and China
tomorrow South Korea's military launched
guided missiles into the sea overnights
the US officials say the time window for
diplomacy is closing David Martin is at
the Pentagon with the new efforts
punished countries that trade with North
Korea David good morning good morning
North Korea's dictator Kim jong-un is
ruthless unpredictable and young enough
to be Donald Trump's son and he is
rapidly becoming the president's worst
nightmare
after their surprise of North Korea's
first test of an intercontinental
ballistic missile the US ambassador to
the UN nikki Haley said America is
prepared to respond one of our
capabilities lies with our considerable
military forces we will use them if we
must but we prefer not to have to go in
that direction she also said the world
is on notice and warned action is
required like tougher economic sanctions
against Kim jong-un's regime we will not
look exclusively at North Korea we will
look at any country that chooses to do
business with this outlaw regime Haley
was talking about US trade restrictions
against countries doing business with
North Korea and she was singling out
China much of the burden of enforcing UN
sanctions rests with China
ninety percent of trade with North Korea
is from China China's ambassador to the
UN called the North Korean missile test
unacceptable but the hard fact is UN
sanctions have done little to stop North
Korea's nuclear weapons program neither
of us military shows of force like this
launching of precision guided missiles
just across the Demilitarized Zone from
North Korea
former Defense Secretary Leon Panetta if
we just continue to do what we're doing
now I think the chances are very good
that not only will they have an ICBM
capability but they'll develop a
miniaturized nuclear weapon that they
can put on top of that weapon as well
president Trump once thought China that
solve a North Korea problem but then he
found out that Chinese trade with North
Korea has actually increased and he
tweeted so much for China working with
us but we had to give it a try he will
have a chance to give it another try
when he meets with China's president
tomorrow in Germany Nora
interested to see what comes out of that
meeting David thank you so much